luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome back
to the lay hyalpun show i'm super excited for
today it's going to be really interesting um i
am live in miami which is super exciting um so
this is actually powered by the vc firm icon plus
capital um wants to buy block fi they give amazing
interest rates so definitely check them out i've
left a link um everywhere for you um i think you
can get up to like i think it's i don't know four
percent interest or something like that which is
much better especially across europe because
you're getting negative interest rates there
um also guys don't forget because this month um up
until october so i'm giving away a free version of
my audiobook if you do have the paperback on
dressing bitcoin so if you have the paperback
then just let me know and i'm giving away a free
version of my audiobook all right guys so today
let's kick this off joining me is the founder
of insanely addictive fitness and previously the
director of business development at ok coin it is
alex feinberg alex how are you i'm doing great how
are you doing i'm good i'm good it's good to meet
you we're about to you right now i'm in austin
texas i had to uh to move to one of the two free
states in the u.s and so texas was one of them
and oh where were you before well you know i i
spent about 10 years in silicon valley um and you
know maybe just as a background for me and your
audience um you know after i finished uh playing
professional baseball well maybe as a as a start
you know i want i perceived freedom my entire
life and i as a young kid i thought that athletics
would be a vehicle for me to achieve that and so
i um i worked very hard in high school to
get a college baseball scholarship played
at vanderbilt university got drafted by the
colorado rockies played two years in their
uh organization before kind of realizing that my
career was coming to the end of the road i ended
up connecting with one of the boosters for my
college baseball team who gave a quarter million
dollars to the university about 10 years ago
to sponsor a trip to asia for the baseball team
and um you know he and i got to chatting i
had no idea he ran a hedge fund at the time
but a lot of people were encouraging me to
get into finance uh because of my background
in sports and my economics major and i knew he
was a weird dude but um he was he believed in
conspiracy theories he flew me around on a private
jet when i was 23 years old telling me about
uh you know corruption in the u.s government
he gave up his citizenship in the early 90s
um and he really hated the federal reserve and
you know this was before it was popular to hate
the federal reserve he really really hated the
federal reserve like i remember we went to uh
to las vegas and uh we were playing blackjack and
he's playing he won like fifteen thousand dollars
in an hour and we go up to his uh hotel room and
he's just complete just bitching about the federal
reserve and at the time you know this is before
i had like read the creature of jekyll island
even though as a uh economics major i didn't
really understand the financial system that well
um but you know after he asked me if i wanted to
work for him i took the conspiracy theories that
he believed in seriously because he was worth
a hundred million dollars and i wasn't and one
of the conspiracy theories that he believed that i
believe because i read the federal reserve act was
that the federal reserve uh was and is a private
corporation and so um you know working at his
hedge fund in hong kong for a year and a half in
2010 to 2011 um sort of made me believe okay this
game is rigged and the manner in which it's rigged
is going to dump liquidity uh into speculative
markets of which silicon valley is probably the
most speculative market at the time and still now
and so if i want to position myself to make the
most money i can without working you know harder
than everybody else i need to find a way to get
back to silicon valley where i actually grew up
and so i moved back to silicon valley in 2011 um
figured out a way elevator pitched frankly my way
into google um you know using a lot of the you
know psychological frameworks that i learned
as a competitive athlete like understanding uh
different heuristic models that people use to
uh to make decisions i basically um use those
to my advantage i currently coach other people
to use those to their advantage if they want um
elevator pitched my way into google uh ended up
taking a sales role worked there for about six
years um prior to uh then taking the director of
business development position at ok coin shortly
after the crypto market started rallying in 2017.
and so i lived in san francisco for about 10
years and then got the f out of there march
14th 2020 when it looked like black friday in the
stores and i was like uh what is this covid thing
i do not want to be in an urban area um so i
spent last year in idaho where my mom moved
for several months and then decided at 34 years
old i don't want to live with my mom actually
um and so austin texas ended up being the
spot uh that i moved to uh because with my
current business i thought it would be uh the most
advantageous to just interact with people who um
want to eat delicious food and get jacked and uh
do it more simply than uh they think they have to
that is a crazy story i didn't know you were at
google so i'll go into all of that in a bit but
um i'm really interested to hear these conspiracy
theories which he was telling you so other than
the federal reserve what other conspiracies was he
telling you and wait how did you meet this guy i
must have missed that yeah so he gave he was a fan
of my my college baseball team and we always knew
he was a weird guy because just you communicate
with him he's like this guy's a little bit off
but what's weird what's weird like is it because
he's into conspiracies or is he just no well i
didn't know i didn't know that at the time i
first knew he was weird before i knew he was
in the conspiracy theories i first knew he was
a rich weird guy um and but i only talked to
him a couple times and then the fall of 20 2009
sorry the winter 2009 was my last shortly after
my last year of professional baseball i uh began
to chatting with this guy because i knew he had
businesses in hong kong and he was rich and i was
interested in foreign currency trading and his son
friended me on facebook and i pinged his son said
hey i'm interested in fx trading does your dad
know anybody who might be able you know who might
be interested in chatting with me turns out his
dad trades fx so it's like okay great i was hoping
to use your dad for an introduction but maybe you
can just re like reconnect me with your dad um and
so you know he believes in a lot of them um and
i wouldn't say that i'm i've been sold on all of
the conspiracy theories that uh that he believes
but um you know he obviously the the fed being a
private bank uh he thinks it's controlled by the
rothschild family which you know if looking at the
research at the time it's it's plausible that it
was uh it's from the research i did really really
tough to definitively say that that's the case
now but i think he probably believes that it's
the case now um you know jfk a lot of people
you know will think that there's something
going on with the cia and maybe the fed and
all that well that's where the word conspiracy
theory came from anyways right right with uh
with how the the cia you know basically made
it up to disparage people who challenged them
um he thinks 911 is an inside job oh wow okay
so he's full on uh tin foil hat and everything
yeah um you know belief on global warming
i don't think he believes in global warming
or i i don't know what he's actually it's climate
change now by the way i'm going to change it
i don't know what his actual beliefs are
he definitely doesn't have the mainstream
view of climate change but i don't know if he
thinks it's it's directionally happening just
not to the extent the models uh will definitively
say it is um but he thinks very much for himself
and you know i think what's important for a lot
of people at every stage of their life is a lot
of the best advice that you get is going to
be uncomfortable advice because it's actually
challenging an assumption that you have that is
wrong and it's very uncomfortable for people to
remove wrong assumptions because it makes
the world seem scarier than it really is
but uh you know as a young money motivated
man uh i knew he had 100 million dollars
and i didn't and so it was like dude you're
like this guy has accomplished more than you
uh in all likelihood because
he thinks differently than you
so you should at least do your best to evaluate
what he's saying and make your own decision on
it do not dismiss it just because it makes you
feel uncomfortable and so you know this guy he
he's up 200 million dollars on his bitcoin
trade from last year he would just he sent
me his you know he i think he probably put
at the time maybe half of his net worth um
you know sold a quarter of it just to cover his
initial uh initial bet and so with the 75 profit
uh of his initial trade he's up like a lot and so
um you know you always look at the scoreboard to
determine whether people's ideas insane ideas
are actually insane and if the scoreboard says
they're not saying then it's actually well no
they're geniuses actually they just see things
differently than you and the reason why they're
rich and you're not is because they can connect
thoughts that you can't or refuse to yeah i think
you're absolutely right i think that's where a lot
of people tend to go wrong um in society they
often look at major successful people and and
hear what they have to say and then just shut them
down and say no they're dumb you know rather than
saying hang on what could i potentially learn
from this um so that's great that's a that's a
real turning point for you in your life um yeah go
on sorry oh i think so and i think yeah a lot of
people you know when we chat they're like oh you
know you played professional baseball and then
you worked at a hedge fund and then you worked
at google how you know how did you do all that
and the reality is um each group is a social
unit it's just people and and so with within
every context it's competitive humans working in a
group to try to win things and so once you realize
that the way you know the commonalities between
competitive groups of humans trying to win things
um exceeds any differences that they have so
the the uh the event in which they're competing
actually matters less than the fact that
this is a group competition um that humans
are participating in uh and if you understand the
human dynamics you understand the human psychology
that underpins it all you can actually fluidly
jump from industry to industry um without actually
having having the industry expertise of people
who worked in it for like five or six years
and so you know had i not um played baseball
at a high level i would not have forced myself
to uh reassess the world that i lived in and
thought i understood um because i wouldn't
have seen people who i had previously designated
as less intelligent than me continued to succeed
in ways that i couldn't and so i think forcing
myself to humble myself enough to uh reframe
and redefine uh what i believed intelligence to
be which i had to do as a competitive athlete
really made it easy for me to open my mind to new
ideas like federal reserve conspiracy theories
in 2010 or really opened my eyes to new ideas
like understanding how corporate america works
when i started working at google and then
i think because i took an open mind to it
i was able to identify different paths
that other people could not identify
i was you know able to um create the fitness and
eating programs that i've that i now monetize
um in my spare time and it's simply from
keeping an open mind and knowing that
you know there's probably a better way to do it
than what everybody else assumes they're just kind
of too lazy and stubborn to uh to go through the
cognitive discomfort of continually questioning
and reassessing their assumptions that cognitive
discomfort is um exactly just what reminds me of
the matrix and everything that's going on in
the world right now and this i titled this
show bitcoin and tyranny um so i kind of want to
talk about there's so much we can talk about but
let's go into why bitcoin and why crypto for
you because you know you obviously have this
sports background then a financial background
but why bitcoin why do you care about it where
does that bitcoin and fitness come in yeah so
i think i've always been an independent-minded
person i think since i played baseball uh in
college um i came to view the world as you
know people control other people and so you know
despite the fact that i'm very anti-marxist and i
yeah i see communism rising in the united states
and i don't like it makes me very uncomfortable
um i could actually probably generate uh more
positive statements towards marxism and communism
um than 95 of the of americans despite
the fact that i hate it more than 98
of americans are 99 of americans because so
wait what what positive things would you say the
the general diagnosis of uh you know of economic
and resource distribution of marxism is true
the thing that's wrong is the is the conclusion
of okay now what do we do like in a capitalist
society you will have capital aggregating in
the hands of a small small number of people and
these people will create rules um to make it more
challenging for the smaller people to accumulate
capital and essentially maintain decent standards
of living that's correct what's incorrect is okay
now the workers of the world need to rise up and
take over the the industries that were exploiting
them and uh and everything will be jolly it's like
no i think history's proven that that's not going
to happen in that way and a lot of people are
going to die and end up in gulags but i very much
believed the um the game of exploitation was there
and you know i saw it working in corporate america
um where you know a lot of times uh you know
employees would believe certain narratives and
you just look at the math and you're like that's
not true what they're telling you is not true you
can look at the earning statement and know that
that's not true um or you know do you know how
little equity you have in the startup that you're
working in have you asked them how many shares are
outstanding oh no you haven't okay so your stake
is one over infinity you should assume it's zero
um and so just seeing people be exploited um
in commercial environments um and in sports
environments uh you know frankly at certain
junctures in my uh my baseball journey um
you know really made me put a high price on my
own personal sovereignty um and i and i understood
that in a capitalist system you know owning assets
gives you freedom it's a very direct path to
freedom and if you can't own the assets at least
you need to own the uh the source of income that
you're reliant upon because if you don't they're
going to make your life increasingly difficult
quarter after quarter by placing higher and higher
expectations for the same you know roughly the
same wage and so i very much didn't want to
do that i also uh understood for many years
that nothing backs the us dollar other than you
know our propensity to fight wars to make sure
that it's used as an international settlement
currency and so you know despite the fact that i
was in coinbase's office in december 2013 meeting
with their director of business development
i think shortly after they raised money at like
125 million valuation um i actually thought
the government was going to make bitcoin illegal
because of what i had yeah i mean i had studied uh
you know different conspiracy theories around uh
you know what we did with uh gaddafi like the real
reason why we took out gaddafi the real reason
why we took out saddam and i don't know if it's
a singular reason but i do think the fact that
they're trying to create currencies to circumvent
uh the dollar as a settlement currency certainly
um added to uh why they were on the bad boy list
and uh and so i thought well yeah like there's
no way the government is going to let this thing
take off um so i never you know despite the fact
that i was getting bullying delivered to my office
in 2011 2012 at google literally i was getting
like thousands of dollars of bullying delivered
and there's this coin based company down the
street that was hiring you know bd reps and i
was like yeah but that's not going to do anything
um in 2017 when bitcoin started taking off and it
started getting a little bit of institutional
backing i think goldman was opening uh
planning to open a crypto trading desk at that
point i thought okay well the people who own our
government seem to be financially incentivized
profit off of crypto so if those people um
have the regulatory connections that
the industry at large generally lacks
you know i think this thing can take off and and
the fact that there is nothing backing the dollar
tells me that you know frankly any currency
can be used as a currency so long as people
believe in its validity and it has some degree
of functionality fungibility you know some of
the main characteristics of a currency um and
i thought well there's no reason why bitcoin
can't potentially be that um if i'm i think
was 31 years old at the time when i left google
and uh entered the crypto space and i thought
you know the up this industry is growing very
fast there's going to be so many opportunities
here even if i can't pinpoint one in particular
you know i left google before i had my job
offer lined up because i was so certain
that uh something good was would happen you
know so i made over 200 000 my last year at
google had worked there for six years and i just
quit without another offer lined up because i
was confident enough um in my ability to sink
in a ever-changing environment and find my way
and find my path you know these ideas and these
views are really uncommon i think that's why a
lot of people tend to um just gravitate towards
twitter and meet a lot of like-minded people so
at google google is is known as you know like
the big tech lefty kind of way of doing things so
i wonder what was it like having these having
these views and then also trying to navigate
a world where you're trying to find like-minded
people who also see the world the same way as you
and also don't think you're crazy or a conspiracy
theorist like how has that been yeah so i i
noticed at when i was in college you know i was an
economics major took marketing classes investment
classes i noticed that people who uh wore suits
well um and were good-looking were always seen as
more credible and so because i i didn't realize
this when i was younger but when i when i was
younger i would say i struggled with credibility
and not because the things i said weren't true
in retrospect in retrospect it was because i
thought in ways that nobody else could understand
and and the things that i would think and say
uh were a very significant departure of the of
the starting assumptions that the people
i would speak with had and so they just
assumed i was like making things up and so
i noticed when i was in college like oh well
people who look good in suits who speak well
seem to be more believable like we have these
people come into our classes and like literally
they could say anything and i would think that
it was true i knew this i had the self-awareness
and so a big reason why i stuck with my diet and
my fitness regimen my entire corporate career was
because i knew that if i was going to have ideas
that a lot of people thought were crazy
um it was my duty to be in very good shape
and and be able to look good in a suit because all
of a sudden you know if you if you think the same
way as a guy who wears a tin foil hat but you can
wear a custom tailored suit with nice links and
speak you know articulate english all of a sudden
your crazy idea seems like oh that's interesting
i don't i don't really necessarily know what
alex is saying but he's thought it through
deeply and so that's kind of the relationship
that i had with my colleagues at google where
um the company you know did change
very much in six years that i was there
um very similar to how uh you know social systems
change social systems tend to start libertarian
and and devolve into liberalism um you can look
at california california only elected republican
governors for like its first 70 years like almost
exclusively you can go on wikipedia and look at it
you know who uh represented it or who was in uh
san francisco uh who san francisco mayors were
for the first half of the 20th century almost all
republicans and then as uh as their model grew to
be functional and larger and more people came in
and they started offering more social benefits and
that types to attract a different type of person
and the way companies work whether it's uber or
whether it's google companies work the exact same
way the core founding team tends to be aggressive
libertarians and as they scale they need to start
recruiting people from liberal universities who
think differently and and tend to be attracted
to a stable paycheck which it will be a very
different type of person than the person
who wants to build something on their own
and so when i joined google in 2011 it was still a
libertarian leaning company but by the time i had
left uh it did seem like it had you know very
meaningful marxist inclinations but i will say
that with all the lessons that i learned in my
life um playing sports dealing with the media
um you know working in finance learning how to
say uncomfortable things in a digestible way
kept me sane because when like i don't know if you
remember when google fired james moore for writing
the diversity memo that he wrote um you know that
memo is based on the the videos of jordan peterson
that i've been consuming like 20 hours a week
all 2017. and so i knew exactly what the guy
was saying at the time um but nobody else did
and so when we had our like team powwow to
discuss everybody's feelings after that uh that
memo started going uh viral within the company
i was the only person of 15 or 20 on my team
to raise my hand and say i think that what he
said was true and my team was 50 women and i
had one-on-one discussions with the majority
of them and it wasn't threatening i wasn't
like badgering them i was just saying like
yeah like this guy is like one of the
smartest people i've ever heard speak
and i really like there's many reasons that i
believe that this is true and like i looked into
a lot of the data and a lot of the and i could
like articulate the actual studies you know
um when you talk about trait neuroticism between
men and women it's like you can just go look
at the study i remember one of the researchers
names costa the study includes over 20 000 people
and it talks about the the mean differences in
um in trade neuroticism propensity to negative
emotions between men and women and it's like the
study says that there's maybe a quarter standard
deviation difference between the two cohorts
across countries and there's only four countries
in the world where it didn't exist and those
countries are not exactly seen as the bastions of
women's rights so you know what's your take on
this and they had no response obviously and they
couldn't get mad at me because they knew i wasn't
coming at them um in an aggressive way i was just
like look we're neither of us know 100.0 percent
of what's out there but this is what i've seen and
the best way that i can interpret this is this
way what do you think and it was always okay
it was always okay for me to say um what i
believed because of the way that i said it
yeah i think that's something that jordan peterson
does really well um you know he wears the suit
he um speaks incredibly well he makes um small
like sorry complicated ideas he makes them very
simple um but my only thing with him is i'm a huge
fan like absolutely love him but he doesn't fully
get the pass you know like you were saying if you
look nice and you look uh you know you're not you
don't look like a crazy person with a tinfoil hat
people still don't understand him people still
don't understand his ideas um like did you see
have you seen the famous kathy newman interview
of course i've seen the cat well yeah kathy newman
intentionally didn't understand his ideas that was
a little bit different i think kathy newman was
smart enough to understand what he was saying and
i don't think she was although i shouldn't have
put herself in a situation where she just got so
embarrassed and she's now a meme oh interesting i
i assume that she knew she was like totally full
[ __ ] but oh absolutely not no way interesting
well you know in this speaks very much to the
arrogance of the institutional class which i
think would be a very uh interesting topic of
discussion because it very much overlaps into
uh corporate work and crypto is you know i
i grew up as an athlete so even though i went to
uh you know top 20 university in the united states
um i didn't you know i didn't consider myself an
academic i didn't consider myself an intellectual
it wasn't until i got out of school i
took a gmat realized i scored higher
than other people who would get admitted to top
business schools um that i thought oh you know
maybe i am like smart and then i started working
with people who went to ivy league schools and
i started to understand the way that they thought
and and the way that they thought incorrectly
and then you started to see
some sort of commonality um
between their the incorrect thoughts that
they had um and the incorrect thoughts that
permeated through corporate america whether they
started from mckinsey and company or started from
some internal think tank at a tech company
you start realizing that there are common
uh ways that these people misunderstand reality
um and they're they're both ignorant and arrogant
um with respect to uh to to this reality and
so kathy newman i guess you know from what
you're saying it is very possible that um you
know that she had no idea because these people
don't know that there are very very meaningful
counter-arguments to what they're saying
yeah absolutely um you're a mute i don't know
definitely not meant to be amazing okay stuff
going on in the background oh no no i can't
hear anything um yeah no absolutely i i there's
definitely a huge level of arrogance um but no i
look i look i think you're right i think um one of
the biggest problems especially during the trump
era was um a lot of trump fans or whatever had
a really difficult time because the media would
constantly pick um people who didn't come across
as well educated they didn't look very intelligent
and so they were really able to sort of portray um
you know the trump fans or whatever as these crazy
hillbilly type um uneducated people and obviously
that's not entirely the case if you know
the majority of america voted for him um
well i don't know i don't think to be clear
a majority of america did not vote for him
well he still lost the uh no i meant previously
no no he's still lost in 2016 then the yes but
you know what i mean in terms of just like how
how it works he was elected as president yeah
yeah that's how propaganda works is you take a
small subsection of your opponent and and you
know in a large country 340 million people every
group has idiots and you just say well they're
all these people and what's so funny is you know
i disagree with my doubt on a lot of these things
because i uh you know he's probably more communist
sympathizing and i would say i'm more right at
this point or center i don't know some combination
of center right center left um and uh and you know
he said oh you know have you seen these trump
rallies have you seen this you've seen that i'm
like dad have you looked at the data because all
of the things that you're saying about republic
conservatives that they're uh you know neurotic
um jealous um you know all of the you know like um
all of the negative stigma that the mainstream
media paints conservatives if you just google
um you know political differences and mental
disorders and you just like look at the first
few articles that come up this is google 2021
i don't know how they're going to change the
results in 22 or 23. what comes up it shows that
the same things that they say are exist in the
republican party are actually statistically
more prevalent in the democratic party
that there's a greater degree of mental illness
and i think greater degrees of uh of you know
jealousy envy all this stuff uh that that exists
on the left than the right so it's like you know
you're you're it's a pot calling the kettle
black like that's your group that you're saying
yeah no absolutely i think for me personally i
just find that there's so much division right
now and um i feel like it's only getting worse
and you know i always say they with my vague they
they will continue to make this division even
more intense um you know with vaccinations and
things like that um but i often look at crypto and
bitcoin as something which hopefully can bring us
together although there's still further division
so when you you you were saying you know you
decided to leave this secure job at google um to
go into crypto or just to go and do whatever else
you wanted to do so that takes a lot of conviction
so can you tell me you know where that conviction
comes from and really just like where where
you see bitcoin's place in the world given
everything we've spoken about in terms of you
know politics and tyranny yeah so i think um
you know you in retrospect you could say it took
a lot of conviction it also just aligned with some
frustrations that i had uh yeah in a regular
corporate job and i had been looking for years
for uh you know i would say faster moving
opportunities um and you know as i mentioned
i was in the coinbase office in 2013 which i'd
only been at google for like two or three years
at that point two two full years at that point
um but it took me six years to leave because
i was very picky about uh the different bets i
would take i knew that a lot of people who left
for startup roles got worse jobs than they left
at google had to work harder for less money and
very limited equity upside and i wasn't interested
in doing that and so when i saw this big wave and
everything rallying in the altcoin market in late
2017 um yeah i mean i thought it was overbought i
didn't think it would crash by 90 but i thought
it would crash by 50 or something like that
um and so to me it was just like there are a ton
of smart people in this space uh there's a ton of
capital in this space if you have if you combine
those two things a lot of good things happen
so this is a very non-academic assessment like
i wouldn't be able to write this assessment in
the mckinsey report um and uh you know if i worked
at mckinsey and have my boss say that's okay it's
like you only need to know two things there's a
lot of smart people and there's a lot of money
and so generally speaking when those two things
intersect a lot of good things happen it doesn't
you don't need to create mathematical
models around it you don't need to do
case studies around it you don't need
to do typical consulting work or typical
analytical work that would be expected of you
in a corporate job you just know that something
good is going to happen and so that was sort of
the extent of the thought process that i've had
and frankly with the best decisions i've made
in my life they've been made with um uh i guess
very simplistic motivations like to that extent
and and if i think about the you know the few
best decisions i've made in my life none of them
have taken more thought process than that despite
the fact that a lot of the other things i do in
my life um do you take a lot of thought process
and we were speaking earlier you mentioned that
there was certain kind of propaganda going on
at google i'd love to understand more about this
yeah so i actually write about this um in my cheat
codes for surviving corporate america um you know
for those of you who've who just started following
me on twitter maybe just coming across me today
i initially got my start um on the fitness side
which i'm sure leona we'll get to later um well
i can cover it now android entering the crypto
space in a sales role um with a very small twitter
account in 2018 i told myself because industries
are constantly changing i told myself that if i
don't have 10 000 followers on my twitter account
um within two or three years i will not be
employable in this capacity in the crypto
space because i think anybody who's paying me at
that level will expect that i have some degree
of distribution uh greater than just my rolodex
so i'm going to need to build a crypto account
and um you know what i had realized from my uh
hobbies which included lifting weights and eating
delicious food over the prior five years is i
noticed that i was able to to get results that
were a lot easier um than what most people got
with mainstream fitness i never counted calories
i never went through a you know calorie cut i
didn't i was training less and less and eating
more and more enjoyable food and i thought
oh there's over 100 million americans who are
diabetic or pre-diabetic or obese so if they knew
it could be as easy as i've found out it could be
um this is probably one of the best ways i can
impact the world so i'm gonna create a crypto or
a twitter account around this content specifically
and then once i can get to grow it to five or ten
thousand people then i can start talking about
more crypto stuff because at the time i didn't
really have a very unique um perspective on crypto
and so um that was sort of how how my twitter
account um came up and i forget exactly why i
mentioned that but specific to your question on
propaganda at google um i'm i i'm constantly
playing cognitive games within my own mind to
reframe issues objectively because what i've
noticed uh as an adolescent and young adult and
now getting into middle-aged adult is that any
time somebody's trying to spin something on you
um they will take something that's mathematically
one way and they will present it as if it's not
like that and so a lot of times uh the
way institutionalists will do it is by
pretending that the ideas that they have
that are subjective are objective in a way
that a large company can do that is they say
well the promotional process works like this
it's like okay that's a negotiation right that's
not that that is your side coming to the table and
say this is how this is the rate uh that we're
willing to raise your uh raise your salary at
um and and we are not willing to raise it
uh in excess of x um across y period of time
so i view this as a negotiation i don't view this
as a rule it's something objective it's like no
this is what they they came up with to maximize
their own profits and i disagree with it whereas
a lot of very nice kind corporate employees uh
friendly colleagues of mine like literally could
not see outside the box that the compensation
structure in the promotional structure uh was
designed to maximize the extraction of value on
behalf of the shareholders of you and and you are
being set up and and this is the case of employees
at every publicly traded company is you're a major
uh line item that the cfo needs to account for
needs to figure out how to not let that line item
grow dramatically and so that's why they hire hr
teams to uh then hire compensation consultants to
figure out what is the easiest way they can
uh not pay you more for as long as possible
without having you leave and so like if all you
do is see things okay what is this person's job
why does the the svp of hr report to the cfo
and not the chief revenue officer oh because
they're responsible for costs not production or
more costs than production okay so if they're
responsible for managing costs and they create
these rules what do you think these rules are for
um and so just just understanding the
world quantitatively and mathematically
um is i would say a necessary precondition to
seeing the world objectively um because you
can keep track of things and you can keep score
and so when you know that uh you know the score
the scoreboard continually favors one side over
the other you know then it's very possible that
the people who are constructing the rules of the
game did it in a way to affect that outcome um and
that's kind of like how corporate propaganda works
and so you said so when we were speaking you you
were saying that you're seeing these similarities
um with the biden administration so explain that
to me so when i see jen paske if i'm saying
her last name speak uh she to me speaks exactly
exactly her mannerisms uh her tone her cadence
exactly like a full of [ __ ] consultant
i don't know what her background is i assume
she worked at mckenzie or something like that
wait who are you talking about again the
white house press secretary oh yes yes yes
yeah yeah i don't know what her background is
but she communicates her communication style
is exactly the same well i it probably works for
a lot of people like that's a fairly elevated
position and i'm sure was very competitive that a
lot of sociopaths were gunning for um and you know
of all of the people they could have picked they
picked her so she probably does bring something to
the table that a majority of people cannot um but
what that means is she's able to communicate in a
way that a lot of people probably like you know i
get these push notifications because apple signed
me up for them for like huffington post and so
on you need to delete that rather i do i do but
um just i just want to say actually just on that
point though i used to have notes i used to have
news notifications i turned them off i deleted
it literally as covert started last year oh it's
probably smart yeah i don't know they're like
auto set up i get like fox news and huffington
post which is like great but to get rid of it
polar sources and so you know i don't know some
a couple people like ten a thousand a million like
some degree of people like her um but when i see
her talk um she speaks exactly like uh you know
some sort of corporate vp or mckinsey consultant
who has nothing of substance to say and her main
job is to spin things or obviously it's the real
intention of initiatives um so that's exactly what
i see with her um and and more broadly like uh
whichever political party is in power tends to be
the one that's extremely full of [ __ ] and you
know right now that happens to be the democratic
party yeah i've seen some um i actually didn't
know her name um not being american so um but
i i've seen a lot of different clips of hers
recently um and there's a lot of um avoiding
answering questions i mean that's the that's
just really the biden administration in general um
the whole um the whole i can't remember what bill
they're doing but they were sort of saying that
it's going to cost zero right yeah oh okay sure
but this is what happens when you have true
believers and um you know the the deeper i
get into understanding the world around me it
forces me to understand human psychology and
you know as i mentioned i always argue with
my dad about politics uh unfortunately like
it's we talk on a regular basis and we constantly
disagree on politics and you know one thing that
um i think about the way he thinks and i think
about some of the deficits in his own um cognition
is uh he's very good at analytical thinking except
he has some blind spots that rely on assumptions
that aren't true uh like a few amount of false
assumptions may mean that the conclusions that
he arrives at are completely far off um and
so you know what that means around like his
support of government well he's a little bit of
an anxious person himself he's also not religious
200 years ago a person like that would have been
kind of steered towards some religious community
and said well your anxiety is you know due to
your lack of relationship with god and so the
way you fix that is you know you do this and that
the other thing and um you know because he's a
graduate school educated individual uh who's a
lawyer in the 21st century you know he thinks
he's a little bit beyond that and so he's opted
for the the church of rationality um which has led
into the church of the democratic party um whom he
now sees in some regard as the you know that party
takes this the his brains it fills his brain's
void um that needs a savior right and so when
people people's brains have a void for a savior
and that savior in some people's brains is uh
their concept of a deity and that savior in other
people's brains is the government and so a lot of
people just believe that the government is going
to take care of them the same way other people
whom the government believers think are ignorant
believes a man in the sky is going to take care
of their needs the issue i think is when one
of those beliefs leads to the implementation
of authoritarian policies um you know because a
small percentage of the population is too neurotic
to deal with the realities of life and that it
is dangerous and we cannot plan around everything
and safeguard against everything possible i think
you touched on a really interesting point which is
something i keep hearing recently it's how people
have these conversations with their parents they
have good relationships with their parents their
parents um they hold to high regards you know they
say they're very intelligent they're they're a
doctor or you know they've always sort of seen
the world in in the correct way but when it comes
to recent events our parents just aren't quite on
board aren't quite seeing it the way that we see
it they have these blind spots as you say and i'm
not 100 sure why that is but i do have a theory
in that we're just of a different generation so we
our generation now has access to technology
so we which means we have access to
more ideas so for example jordan peterson right he
has completely changed my entire um perception on
everything everything um like feminism is a
fantastic example i'm not gonna get into it um
but he's completely changed my perspective on it
and um that is something which i don't believe you
know my parents would have had access to um you
know growing up in the 70s i don't know when they
grew up something like that um so it it is really
interesting um is this something that you've
come across you you see more you know parents are
there but not fully there 100 and to build on that
and you know offer my own perspective as to why
that's the case i think you know as we get older
our bodies and our minds become more immobile
because we become lazy enough to only be able
to do the things that we demand of it on a daily
basis and so one thing that your brain does in
your 20s and your 30s probably your 40s is it
starts to recognize um trustworthy sources versus
untrustworthy worthy sources and in our parents
generation the pattern recognition that they
that they relied upon in their 20s 30s and 40s was
oh the new york times is trustworthy oh the cnn
delivers good news and it's the national enquirer
that delivers the fake stuff but the real stuff
um comes from these publications that are under
this brand name that are written in this font
and so that's the shortcut i can use to
know whether it's credible what's the source
and so um that neglects the fact that the same
institutions that carry the same name that write
in the same font um that uh you know have the
reputations that they probably earned and deserved
at one point in their uh in their organizational
lifespan um now they can just make things up
because the employees within those organizations
are very different than the employees within
those same organizations 30 or 40 years ago those
people are not trustworthy now um and and so um
older people who haven't like they're not con
they're you know they basically finish their
pattern recognition that is uh is coloring how
and why they think they are not able to adapt
to the fact that these institutions may once
have been trustworthy but now is not that time
and so they they do not see the value of um
finding alternative information sources um
you know and then and so if you only trust the
mainstream narrative you know you're effectively
in a cult and you don't realize it um because
that cult is telling you all the ideas of the
outsiders are wrong and dangerous and scary and
they're going to lead to white nationalism and
all these things and it's like dude have you
gone outside does what you're seeing on tv
align at all with what you see in the real world
um or you like data here these are government
statistics that are not even being referenced
in the articles that you're talking about
um if that was a genuine concern of the author
and the and the most reliable statistics directly
refute the point that the art the author's making
um stats can be wrong but it's incumbent upon the
author to at least reference the fact that the
stats do contradict him or her and and offer a
reason for why those statistics are wrong but they
don't they just pretend that those stats don't
exist which is how you know that they're not being
genuine in their intent yeah i think that right
now we are going through a really interesting
shift and um just to bring this conversation back
to crypto i do think that we it's sort of that
safe haven for these ideas and this free thinking
this alternative way of seeing the world and so i
do i do hope you know i i think somebody's written
in the comments they're talking about like a
civil war coming and people often talk about
like florida and texas breaking away from america
and all this stuff but i do think that something
is coming in in some ways i don't necessarily
mind because i think that we need this crazy
um reality check you know whether it's like forced
vaccines whether it's covert restrictions for the
fourth year or the third year whatever it is now
um i do think that we we do need something to
to really wake people up i don't know we'll
have to see what happens but well i wrote an
article a year ago before trump got kicked off of
twitter uh that said and before bitcoin i think
even crossed 20k definitely not yeah and i wrote
you know bitcoin the currency of the canceled so
you guys can probably google that title and
it would come up under my medium page and uh
and so i kind of thought like as more people get
cancelled um and get kicked off of mainstream
financial platforms exactly um they're going to
end up using bitcoin and so what i actually see
happening with the political disagreements that
are occurring in the u.s is there's a recurring
need for the people on the left to inflate
and that includes the fbi um to inflate the
threat of white supremacy and and there's a
few key in like toxic masculinity there's a
few key issues where you're like what these guys
like it doesn't matter what's going on they just
really really want to make sure that you're scared
of this thing whether it's russia white supremacy
yeah and so it's like okay clearly they have an
agenda to make sure that you're scared of this
thing um clearly there's some sort of uh agenda
to force medical decisions on other people and
they're trying to make the two things intersect
in people's minds like any good propagandist would
and so you know what do i think the next uh you
know the next domino to fall could be uh you also
know the left is trying to ban guns um and yeah if
you'll notice in the in the us relative to other
countries that have banned guns the us doesn't
have lockdowns that are quite as severe as many
of the countries that have banned guns although
there's not guns in scandinavia and but that's
a little bit of a different thing that's going
on there and um and so what i see happening is
you know for simple descent you know when you
say well toxic masculinity is a problem toxic
masculinity is actually a space holder for dissent
and so uh instead of saying well we don't want to
dissent is dangerous they can't say that just
yet um so they say well who are going to be the
most likely loudest dissenters men okay so let's
just stigmatize toxic masculinity um so we don't
have to directly stigmatize dissent we can just
uh stigmatize the people who are most likely to
dissent yes and so what's what's going to end up
happening because it's a large country is if they
end up taking more aggressive measures to force
medical decisions on other people uh or limit
their ability to uh make an income if they don't
submit to medical decisions being made for them
uh you know one person of a hundred million is
going to do something stupid because that's what
happens when you have freedom and 100 million
people is someone's going to do something dumb
and so you know if that person ends up uh you
know shooting up some people uh which would be
unfortunate obviously um but not unlikely
in a country that has 340 million people
like one person is going to go crazy
every day you can guarantee yourself that
um they're going to use that as a excuse to like
shut down uh dissent of the left and so imagine
what would happen if one day you know uh there
was some sort of uh uh you know mo i mean look
at how they're responding to january 6 they're
massively inflating a non-insurrection for being
an insurrection so obviously if there's any sort
of uh domestic pushback that includes anything
violent they're going to blow that so far out of
proportions uh that is in the government and then
what's going to happen is because the government's
blown it out of proportions the institutionalists
who populate these big tech companies are then
going to say oh yeah well the government made this
declaration therefore we need to do the
responsible thing and not just kick off
the the people who are directly involved from
the platforms but kick off anybody who's like
within two degrees of them from platforms because
we need to kill this cancer before it spreads
okay so what would that mean for somebody like
you or somebody like me you know even though you
know we will denounce violence and not be anywhere
close to participating in something like that uh
because we may have like commented on the same
tweet as this as the person uh we get put on some
list uh we get kicked off these platforms we get
our paypal accounts banned and then all and then
you know possibly you know there's some financial
account restriction too that could happen and
none of these things seem plausible now but you
realize that once one thing happens the overton
window shifts and new things become conceivable
that were previously inconceivable and that
is how i think bitcoin could end up becoming an
alternative currency for the canceled yeah i mean
that always reminds me um of piers morgan
because he did an interview with ben shapiro
and ben shapiro was explaining the need for
guns and ben shapiro was basically saying
um if you don't believe that your government could
become tyrannical and therefore you need a gun to
protect you and your family then you're naive
and you know you can sort of look at that and
say um at the time oh he's just being a conspiracy
theorist he's being you know overly concerned but
when you look at the state of the world and what's
happened over the last 18 months nearly two years
um anything is possible now so um i wouldn't yeah
so i wouldn't rule anything out um but alex what
tell me what you're working on right now
and where can people um find you and you
know you said you've written some articles
so how can people follow all of this work
yeah i think the easiest way is to follow me on
twitter my handle's alex feinberg one um you know
what i've worked on last year is delicious recipes
that a lot of people eat without really you know
taking care of portion sizes and they find their
bodies are feeling better their workouts are
better and their bodies are looking better i also
have an eating framework that shows how i you know
come to have four or five percent body fat at
35 years old without ever counting calories
along with the training plan that enables it
that's a lot easier than what most people do
so all of those are i talk about those on my
twitter handle all the time and then more recently
uh as i mentioned i've done more um corporate
navigation work so um uh you know in the process
of me working in in the crypto exchange
that i work for from 2018 to 21 uh 2021
also grew this nice twitter handle um and
now a lot more people who are following me
uh realize that a lot of the shortcuts
that i'm seeing in fitness and eating
um you know the same brain that created those or
discovered those also has found a lot of corporate
shortcuts too uh so i've released uh the guide to
uh the cheat codes to survive in corporate america
um also today i released uh the aristocrats guide
to salary negotiation that a lot of people um get
wrong for uh for very understandable but easily
addressable reasons and so um just put that out
i'll continue to push it we've had several people
purchase it already today um and i think that's
gonna help a lot of people out because uh you know
i've recently started working with other people
um one-on-one some on salary negotiation and
we've gotten them like you know 30k raises in
like two months so um you know that's how
you can engage with me i keep my dms open
i will continue to keep them open until probably
it gets too crazy yeah but i'll probably at least
until a hundred thousand followers will keep
them open ah nah i keep them open i've got over
that and i keep them open that's totally fine well
i'll reassess it at that point yeah it's good fun
it's all funny games um but alex i want to thank
you so much it's been so interesting hearing your
perspective guys follow alex he has some really
delicious recipes um i'm always looking at them
i'm just like wow and of course some really unique
perspectives on well come on austin austin you can
actually like eat some i know i i might do since
i'm in miami i might do i do want to go to texas
next yeah i might do it all right you got to
invite to chef alex's kitchen when you come
all right it's officially considered all right
guys thank you thank you so much for watching
and alex thank you so much for coming on thanks
this is great all right see you next week bye